có công nhân nhà máy quá trất yếu đạo tình dân đông đã kiếp trẻ thoát khi bệ trưa
quá trất phát nổ hôm 20 năm.
Video nghĩ lại vụ việc cho thấy một công nhân bỏ trẻ khi thấy khó đen và ngọt
lửa buộc phát xung quanh.
Anh này kiếp trẻ thoát thân dừng như một công nhân khác đã bị hất bằng
lây không chung cùng bệ trưa quá trất.
Tà thông tin, vụ lộ sế ra trưa thứ 8 khiến ít năm 2019, mời chỉ người bị thương
và sáng người mất tích.
Theo cơ quan ủng phó khần cấp, hơn 2 trong nhân viên đã tham gia kêu hộ,
cục môi trường xin thái để phương cũng cứ như viên đến kiểm tra hệ trường của nổ như trưa có công bố trình thức.
Cục viên cáo cư dân gần đó đào hầu trang trong pệ dân trở kết quả.